[Music]
this conclusion stems from the fact that
the absolute alone is true or the truth
alone is absolute one may set this aside
on the grounds that there's a type of
cognition which although it does not
cognize the absolute as science aims to
is still true and that cognition in
general though it be incapable of
grasping the absolute is still capable
of grasping other kinds of
truth but we gradually come to see that
this kind of talk which goes back and
forth only leads to a hazy distinction
between an absolute truth and some other
kind of Truth and that words like
absolute cognition and so forth
presuppose a meaning which has yet to be
ascertained
section 74 left off by suggesting to us
that if we look at the assumptions that
underly skepticism about our ability to
get to know the absolute through
cognition by by actually working through
actively doing science and not just
science in the narrow sense of the term
that we use it today but in hegel's
broader sense of visena science as uh
essentially philosophy carrying out a
systematic uh Exposition that takes into
to account the human being their own
location in history all the development
of Consciousness we've talked about a
lot of this in the preface so um there's
a skepticism about that that says well
we probably shouldn't even try to do
that sort of thing and and you can still
see that around today um that skepticism
is going to recur in philosophy and in
in politics and culture in all sorts of
forms uh throughout all of human history
um most likely so this fear of error
reveals itself as a fear of of the truth
and here in this section um 75 he's
going to talk a lot about truth so we
want to get into that says the this
conclusion about fear of Truth stems
from the fact that the absolute alone is
true or that truth alone is
absolute and now what does he mean by
that that's a great Hegel slogan and
when you whip that sort of thing out
that's exactly the sort of thing that
will get people criticizing he and
saying yeah I mean look at this he
thinks that the fact that my shoes are
actually on somehow that's the
absolute that's not what Hegel is saying
we have to we have to exercise a bit of
Charity a little bit of you know
thinking things through here uh and and
not just uh taking easy pot shots he did
set himself up for something by saying
that didn't he um what does he actually
mean the truest form of Truth where
truth is something that's not just you
know say a proposition and its
connection with something but a deeper
form of Truth a more systematic
integrated form of Truth is only really
available to us through what he's
calling the absolute so what that means
is the totality and this is somewhere
where Hegel is definitely committing
himself to something that goes against
many other uh modes of philosophy so the
the absolute is truth one way you can
think of it as the the system itself as
a totality is what is most true but
truth also if we follow it leads us
there that's what the second part of
that formulation is the truth alone is
absolute so when we grasp something as
true we can also grasp a kind of falsity
within it and in so far as there's still
falsity and this play between truth and
falsity within it that we can grasp as
conscious beings something that that you
know Plato already noted Aristotle
already noted um you know the great
Scholastic philosophers noted and so far
as we can grasp that we're not yet at
truth with a capital T we're not yet at
the
absolute so um he says one may set this
aside on the grounds that there's a type
of
cognition some other kind of cognition
that uh although it does not cognize the
Absolut as science aims to see science
Vena tries to grasp the absolute tries
to grasp truth with a capital T by
understanding everything as best as we
possibly can at this point in history
from the vantage point that we've
allowed ourselves to get to engaging in
all the we can give all these sort of
Provisions right science tries to grasp
that science is the kind of cognition
that is in fact tailored to being able
to do that in part because it's part of
the absolute but there's all sorts of
other modes of cognition that we engage
in and don't those also engage with
things that are true that that's what
Hegel is having his interlocutor say to
him don't those also deal with truths
with you know a small te so he says um
that kind of cognition is still true
right meaning that it actually does meet
its object if I say to you there is a
book here and that book has um 500 and
and something pages I don't know because
these aren't numbered here let's say
it's got 600 Pages if it actually does
have 600 Pages we say that's a true
statement it does describe that that
object but then you can say well who who
cares what's the meaning of that and
then you can say well you know it
matters because you know books over 700
Pages cost a lot more money to print so
if we know that and I'm just making that
up right now actually um but if we know
that about this book that it's got only
600 Pages we know that it's within this
this this margin that we want so you see
truths lead to other truths and we can
sort of widen out the network of truths
and eventually get to something that we
consider to be absolute something that
we consider to have meaning in and of
itself something where we don't have to
say well who gives who cares about that
why does that matter so that's true
that's neat but why do you care um the
absolute is sort of the answer to that
but we have all sorts of other types of
cognition all sorts of other getting to
know things all sorts of active you know
disciplines which do cognize other kinds
or let's even call them uh
domains of of Truth so want to know
about the human body maybe get yourself
an anatomy textbook or take an anatomy
class go to an anatomist who actually
doesn't just have that cognition in a
textbook but but has you know managed to
make that part of his or her mental
makeup and they can look at the muscles
and skeleton and nerves and tell you
something about the human body right
they are engaged with truth but it's not
truth with a capital T I've got a few
examples here that I thought you know I
just play around with think about
mathematics um true mathematics is this
beautiful discipline which is very
attractive um because through it we get
to know all sorts of true things we call
those theor we can prove them within the
system we can even prove a theorem about
the fact that we can't prove all
possible theorems within the system
girdle's incompleteness theorem right
but that's M ma mathematically modeled
mathematically um and it's it's got a
kind of beauty to it um so there is some
there is truth there we can grasp that
other kind of Truth um cooking you may
say now we're like going low scale well
you know um
if you actually think about cooking it's
more than just you know a teaspoon of
this and turn the heat up to this level
and a cup of that um if you really
understand cooking you understand an
awful lot of stuff you understand how
favor flavor profiles work together you
understand something about the history
of the spices that you're working with
or the Providence of the food or how the
uh you know environment that the wine
came from affects the way that the wine
tastes you understand something about
human physiology about how we perceive
things um you know to be a chef is
actually to master quite a body of of
knowledge whether explicitly or
implicitly Neuroscience another great
example everybody's wild about
Neuroscience these days um I'm always a
little skeptical of the claims that get
made but um I don't want to worry about
about that what I want to say is
neuroscience cannot tell you why we do
neuroscience and that ought to concern
you Neuroscience you know I don't think
can tell us a lot of the things that it
claims to tell us um but that's sort of
a quibble about you know how much truth
is actually there and how much of it is
is puffery or reading too much into
things but it can't actually address the
sort of dilemma that would be put to it
by by Socrates in in the fedo saying um
you know if I thought everything could
be reduced to materialism he's not
saying it exactly like this but if I
thought everything could be reduced to
materialism and just a makeup of of you
know configurations of things then these
bones would have gotten themselves the
hell out of here a long time ago and I
wouldn't be waiting around to be
executed um it just pushes problems
further back and you know these are
truths I don't want to say that they're
not hegel's not saying that they're not
either but if we want to see them for
what they really are then they need to
be encompassed within absolute truth and
these other disciplines need to be in
some way not you know that the the the
hegelian philosopher needs to be a chef
and a neuroscientist and a mathematician
but he needs to know enough about these
things enough about the available bodies
of knowledge at the time to be able to
incorporate them within the the
framework that that he or she is working
in otherwise what happens here's what
gets really interesting he says we
gradually come to see that this kind of
talk which goes back and forth only
leads to a hazy distinction between an
absolute truth and some other kind of
Truth and words like absolute and
cognition presuppose a
meaning which is yet to be
ascertained this is an issue those who
are only focused on these these other
kinds of truth let's call them truth you
know small T and say well yeah I
understand that that's not the absolute
truth but I'll I'll let let that worry
about itself I don't need to be
concerned with that I'm just going to
focus here on my discipline they don't
realize that what they do is thereby
Elevate that discipline to the capital T
and then they end up introducing all
sorts of falsities into it by not um
actually thinking through what absolute
truth or what genuine science would
entail um they're just sort of playing
around with words is what hegel's
saying
instead of troubling ourselves with such
useless ideas and locutions about
cognition as an instrument for getting
hold of the absolute or as a medium
through which we view the truth
relationships which surely in the end
are what all these ideas of a cognition
cut off from the absolute and an
absolute separated from a cognition
amount to instead of putting up with
excuses which create the incapacity of
Science by assuming relationships of
this kind mind in order to be exempt
from the hard work of science while at
the same time giving the impression of
working seriously and zealously instead
of bothering to refute all these ideas
we could reject them out of hand as
adventitious and arbitrary and the words
associated with them like absolute
cognition objective and subjective and
countless others whose meaning is
assumed to be generally familiar could
even be regarded as so much
deception for to give the impression
that they meaning is generally well
known or that their notion is
comprehended looks more like an attempt
to avoid the main problem which is
precisely to provide this
notion we could with better
justification simply spare ourselves the
trouble of paying any attention whatever
to such ideas and locutions for they are
intended to ward off science itself and
constitute merely an empty appearance of
knowing which vanishes immediately as
soon as science comes on the scene but
science just because it comes on the
scene is itself an appearance and coming
on the scene it is not yet science and
it's developed an unfolded truth in this
connection it makes no difference
whether we think of science as the
appearance because it comes on the scene
along long side another mode of
knowledge or whether we call that other
untrue knowledge its
manifestation in any case science must
liberate itself from this semblance and
it can do so only by turning against it
for when confronted with a knowledge
that is without truth science can
neither merely reject it as an ordinary
way of looking at things while assuring
us that its science is a quite different
sort of cognition that for for which
that ordinary knowledge is of no account
whatever nor can it appeal to the vulgar
View for the intimations that gives us
of something better to come by the
former Assurance science would be
declaring its power to lie simply in its
being but the untrue knowledge likewise
appeals to the fact that it is and
assures us that for it science is of no
account one be Assurance is worth just
as much as another still less can
science appeal to whatever intimations
of something better it may detect in the
cognition that is without truth to the
signs which point in the direction of
science for one thing it would only be
appealing again to what merely is and
for another it would only be appealing
to itself and to itself in the mode in
which it exists in the cognition that is
without
truth in other words it would be
appealing to an inferior form of its
being to the way it appears rather than
to what it is in and for itself it is
for this reason that an exposition of
how knowledge makes its appearance will
here be
undertaken
section 76 ends with a very important
turning point that I want to call your
attention to right away it's a very long
section and there's quite a bit going on
and I'm probably going to have to erase
the board uh about halfway through this
but I want to stress where he's um
ending up he says for this reason an
exposition of how knowledge makes its
appearance is going to be undertaken
here so what does that mean he's going
to look at in this introduction and then
really through the rest of the
phenomenology how does knowledge how
does science make its appearance not
just how does it show up how does it you
know emerge at one point or another in
history but how does that appearance
actually develop over time and become
something more than just appearance
become Essence this is uh something that
is really Central to the entire hegelian
dialectic so he's he's peeling back the
uh the veil at this point but first
before we get there let's talk about all
these things that Hegel wants us to
consider rejecting in this very long uh
and rather long- winded paragraph where
he says instead of troubling instead of
instead of instead of let's do this
so what we should reject he thinks are
these worries these skeptical worries
about cognition as an instrument or
medium why because they make this
assumption that cognition is something
that's cut off from the absolute and
that doesn't turn out to actually be the
case it's not as if the absolute exists
over there in its Purity all by itself
and then we have our cognition which we
could do epistemology and scrutinize in
in you know all of its respects before
it actually engages with the absolute
over there um we're already conect we're
already connected together we're already
involved in the process as a matter of
fact the process has been going on for a
long time before cuz we call that
process history and epistemology really
for Hegel has to be situated within
history of ideas or history of
Consciousness not the other way around
not first we do our epistemology then
decide whether any of this history stuff
means anything because if you do that
you're actually probably going to decide
that history doesn't mean
anything but you won't do anything
beyond epistemology at that point uh
which is rather boring so that's one
thing that we want to reject another we
want to reject is assuming that science
can't get to the truth um that's done
basically so that we don't have to do
the work of science again I I mentioned
a sort of pragmatic uh feature to this
if you don't actually put yourself into
the mix and try things out even though
you're not 100% certain even though
things are being developed you know as
they're going through even though
they're never completely finished at
least in our experience or our lifetimes
if you don't put yourself in there and
start doing something start cognizing
something instead of just worrying about
whether you can cognize something you
never will do it you never will in fact
get to know
anything Hegel even rejects refuting
these ideas and and approaches now
that's kind of an interesting thing why
doesn't he do a critique of them and say
you know we weigh the pros and cons and
decide nah we shouldn't look at things
this way um or I've got an argument
against them he's he's actually saying
something more like
look some people want to be in those
positions I'm not going to bother
refuting them because I'm actually going
to get on with the work of Science and
the refutation will be in showing them
that you can actually know something you
can actually do something that human
beings can actually develop to to get to
know the absolute or become part of the
absolute or realize that they are the
absolute so these are things he's
rejecting and then he has this
interesting passage where he say he's
not saying we're going to reject these
terms like absolute or cognition or
objective or subjective and we could
think of a lot of other terms in our own
time that people like to use um he says
um the words associated with these these
adventitious and arbitrary ideas the
things we're rejecting uh and countless
others their meaning is assumed to be
generally familiar
so objective and
subjective and ask
yourself if you have to explain those to
somebody else what the hell do they
actually mean can you on the spot give a
satisfactory definition of those terms
I'm willing to bet that you can give a
definition but probably if you start
thinking about it very much you'll see
that perhaps these are not as as uh cut
and dried as you think they're not as
counterposed or they're a bit Messier um
is is subjective always bad you know
Paul rur says there's good subjectivity
and bad
subjectivity what could that possibly
mean and we can say the same thing about
absolute what's the absolute do you know
do I
know does Hegel know is it just a word
that we kind of throw around there it's
it's that thing over there well let's
not call it the absolute then let's just
call it the thing over there you
remember back in the preface when Hegel
said you you know I'm not going to use
the word God for a while because that
word's kind of you know vacated its
meaning I'm going to use words instead
like you know the absolute or being or
you know uh Perfection or the Eternal
I'm going to use words that where we can
grip something in there and the absolute
boy that's one that you can easily turn
into you know anybody's uh shth can mean
whatever you like it to
mean
cognition
knowledge something the modern
philosophers were obsessed
with what is it now hekle is not saying
that you have to be able to give a
perfect understanding of that that would
be actually to be at the end of the
system you know be part of the absolute
but um you do have to have something
better than just knowing how to spell
these words or throw them around in in
conversation you know to Pepper your
your discourse with so he says um a lot
of people assume that these words the
meaning is is generally familiar that's
kind of a deception to give the
impression that their meaning is
generally welln or that their notion is
comprehended their concept is is
understood that would be a
deception remember what is a notion for
Hegel what is
a
begriff it's this thing that's
essentially a self-moving entity where
it becomes its own other so you know
objective if we really grasp the the
notion or the concept of objectivity
objectivity also involves its opposite
and its reincorporation of that opposite
back into itself and it develops in
history so you know if you can't just
have a dictionary definition or you know
a textbook definition that you're going
to use you need to actually you know
think
through that's what the notion means you
need to think through what these things
actually would
mean so he says um thinking that this
notion is comprehended that it's clear
as a day as a bell clear as day uh is
actually a way to try to avoid
understanding the notion it's a way to
try to avoid doing work and sort of
skipping steps you might say if we want
to think about mathematics um or using
Cliff Notes so he says um
they're intended to ward off science
itself and here we're getting to to
another term they're intended to ward
off this systematic visen shaft Lea way
of slowly coming to understand uh what's
actually going on and now I have to do a
little bit of a raer so while I'm doing
that let me once again remind us that
when we're using this term science here
um that's translating hegel's German
visen shaft and visen shaft doesn't just
mean uh the Natural Sciences as we tend
to talk about them or even just the
social sciences um doesn't just mean
scientific method or something like that
it extends to include the history of
Consciousness it involves the knower as
much as the known as part of what is
being known so it's a little bit more
involved than that so Hegel is talking
about science
and
Science and here he's talking about
science and um using this
word
appearance now we often contrast
appearance to reality this is only
apparent it's not real um but appearance
is itself a certain kind of reality we
also can talk about appearance as like
you know this person has just appeared
the the night sky is the moon has just
appeared right that means that it's just
come on the scene and now we're
perceiving one aspect of it uh the Moon
is over there right now it's going to be
over there later perhaps it's low to the
Horizon so it's big and blue and by the
time it gets over there it's going to be
smaller and yellow you know there's all
sorts of things that are going to change
over time science when it's first coming
on the scene is an appearance it's
not uh
fully
developed as
science that is it's not completely
systematic it's not completely worked
out
uh it's not completely
reflexive you know when a science is in
the process of being worked out there'll
be things that we know but we're not
quite sure why we know them or we have
certain results and we're you know we're
confronted with those results and we're
like how the hell did that happen that
way um what does this actually mean that
reflexivity is that process of
reincorporation Hegel talks about this
as you know self other Ing and
reincorporation of the other he talks
about this in terms
of or Transcendence or or overcoming or
sublation is how it's usually translated
but we could think of the this in terms
of reflexivity so he says science when
it comes on the scene is an appearance
in coming on the scene it's not yet
science in a developed and unfolded
truth it hasn't fully become what it's
supposed to be in this connection it
makes no difference whether we think of
science is the appearance because it
comes on the scene alongside another
mode of knowledge so this is another
important thing um we have science and
then we
have
other mode and I'm going to put the you
know possible plural here of
knowledge and the connection that we're
going to want to know is what is the
relationship
between this and this these other modes
of
knowledge
is science counterposed against them
like the true to the false but these are
other modes of knowledge so they can't
just be false
then one this is important one of the
things that makes science what it is is
that it relates itself to other modes of
knowledge and doesn't just you know
banish them and say get out of here
you're there's there's nothing to you
but it takes them in and shows to shows
to us the truth that these other modes
of knowledge are not yet aware of
themselves containing at least that's
hegel's view on it so he says
um it makes no difference whether we
think of science as appearance because
it comes on the scene along another mode
of knowledge that's perhaps better
established already or whether we call
that other untrue knowledge it's
manifestation saying well you know think
about alchemy and chemistry right so
chemistry is developing Through
Chemistry we're getting to know the
world not everything you know not
everything that's science for Hegel is
chemistry right but chemistry would be a
part of it and Alchemy was a discipline
they weren't just puttering around doing
you know totally random stuff they they
had a body of knowledge turned out that
some of it was bunk some of it was based
on you know kind of crazy assumptions
some of it was things that might have
actually worked in another field but
didn't work in terms of of chemical
reactions and and compounds and things
like that um you know because they like
they were interested in Psychology for
example
is the science coming on the scene and
just sort of counterposing itself and
saying I'm the truth you're false or is
it coming on the scene and saying um
we're going to we're going to pull the
draw out of you and leave behind the
husk the empty shell and we're going to
take what's good
um Hegel says in any case science has to
liberate itself from just being
appearance how does it do that well
that's that unfolding that developing
that dialectical process right uh it
does that by turning against that for
when confronted with a knowledge that is
without truth science can near can can
neither merely reject it as an ordinary
way of looking at things why can't it
reject it I'm going to pause on this for
a minute why can't science just reject
it as an ordinary way of looking at
things because it is a
discipline if you want to to be an
astronomer and say that astrology is
actually false even though a lot of
people seem to get something out of it
it's not enough just to point out you
know uh the fact that astrologers aren't
really able to make uh good predictions
about human behavior you have to do more
than that in order to to banish it you
can't just treat it as well that's what
the dummies or the ordinary people
do he says um
science cannot merely reject it as an
ordinary way of looking at things while
assuring us that it's science is a quite
different kind of cognition for which
that ordinary knowledge is of no account
whatsoever nor can it appeal to the
vulgar View for the intimidate the
intimations it gives us of something
better to come science actually has to
deliver it can't just say well you know
in the future it's going to be revealed
that I'm right and you're wrong because
we're actually here in the present so
you know this is is something this is a
point where we ought to actually think
about some of the claims that get made
by scientists today about um you know
metaphysical topics like free will or uh
what addiction is or um you know whether
we can come up with a science of
morality um those are pretty big claims
and you don't get to make those claims
by saying well you know in the future
we'll prove that
XYZ if it's real science you got to
demonstrate that in the in the present
so Hegel
says by the former Assurance by saying
look this is just garbage and we're the
ones who have the truth science would be
declaring its power to Simply lie in its
being but the untrue knowledge likewise
appeals to the fact that it is and
assures us that for for it science is of
no account so here we just have a a
struggle between two things that
are and merely appealing to that's the
way things are these are two different
viewpoints on what
is they're both grasping different uh
parts of what is um so that's that's not
a successful way to to fight the battle
you could say so he says
um the uh one bear Assurance is worth
just as much as another still less can
science appeal to whatever intim
intimations of something better it may
detect in the cognition that is without
truth to the signs which point in the
direction of science for one thing it
would only be appealing again to what
merely is it would just be like pointing
out you know this is this is the way
things are this is the way things are in
that
discipline um for another would only be
appealing to itself and to itself in in
the mode in which it exists in the
cognition that is without truth so if
chemistry is going to say you know that
Alchemy stuff mostly garbage but parts
of it not bad how do you know it's not
bad cuz uh the parts of it that aren't
bad matter what we do again um not all
that helpful to do that you know the
parts of it that aren't bad are going to
allow us to like transform the
whole the whole um economy the culture
that you live in I mean think about the
the sort of things the chemistry has
made possible just think about plastic
for example and what that's that's done
to our our entire life world right but
that was something that was uh you know
a far off idea at one time it's not
something you can appeal to and say um
here's my evidence it's way over there
so he says
um for one thing it would only be
appealing again to what merely is and
for another it only be appealing to
itself and in the mode in which it
exists in the cognition that's without
truth in other words it would be
appealing to an inferior form of its
being to the
way it appears to the way it is at that
time
rather than what it is and angle's going
to use an important term what science is
in
and
for
itself this is a key phrase for
Hegel um I'm going to give you sort of a
clue right here when you see that you
can tell you need to underline that part
and say ah what's been happening right
here is a major part of the dialectical
ADV that we've made up to this point
because it's usually some sort of
consolidation that's going on so he says
that's why we need an exposition of how
knowledge makes its appearance we need
to think about how science goes from
being appearance to being something that
is fully worked out that is fully
developed that is fully unfolded that
deals with
the the
absolute as such